anyway here with reaction all of that is
the co-host of the hit show The Five our
friend Judge Jeanine Pirro is with us uh
judge I think us we've we're now seeing
some cracks it would be and I thought
the canary in the coal mine at least the
first one was Maureen Dowd taking Joe
Biden to task for not recognizing his
four-year-old granddaughter in Arkansas
just called you know frankly heartless
and Solas the next crack that I saw was
last weekend and that's when articles
appeared in the New York Times The
Washington Post and Politico all begin
in our go to territory that we've been
covering about Joe and Hunter Biden and
this these bribery and and and money
laundering allegations now van Jones is
saying out loud what a lot of Democrats
have told people like us privately yeah
we know he's a cognitive mess but we're
going to try and hide it from you all or
hide it from the country what do you
think well I think a couple of things I
think that there there's no question
that van Jones Is Right that the
Democrats are hiding as he says behind
their hands when they talk about Joe
Biden but look the guy is in cognitive
decline who in their right mind in
response to the question what do you
have to say about the rising death toll
in Mount Maui where there it was an ins
Inferno people were literally
incinerated and he says no comment look
that says it all the man is not capable
of being president the question that I
have Sean is whether or not that they
have held it together this long so that
all of a sudden they can bring somebody
out that has already been preordained
where they don't really battle it out in
the Democratic party but just say this
is our guide to run against whomever you
know whatever Republican there is
presumably Donald Trump but I think that
what you talk about with CNN and Van
Jones talking about his cognitive
decline there is no question the man is
not capable of being president can you
imagine what we saw what Putin did this
week can you imagine Putin he is
engaging in a real conversation with
Vladimir Putin I don't think Joe Biden
comes out on top or um you know with Xi
Jinping but then when we've got this
whole thing going on with Hunter Biden
his son you know they bring a
racketeering charge against Donald Trump
and 18 other people the racketeering
statute shouldn't be used against Joe
Biden his son and the Biden crime family
everything is upside down and Americans
feel it instinctively they feel the
Injustice Americans are not used to this
and I think that they are sensing in
their polling that the weaponization of
the justice system by one candidate for
president against another candidate for
president is beyond the pale and I think
that the numbers that Donald Trump is
holding is indicative of that okay so if
we're talking about tonight the
weaponization of Justice when you
compare and contrast the the issue of
Hillary Clinton Joe Biden top secret
classified documents how law enforcement
handled their cases versus the the rate
at Mar-A-Lago the charges brought
against Donald Trump uh okay I I it's a
two-tier justice system you don't have
to be brilliant to figure that out if if
Donald Trump had leveraged a billion
dollars against his own administration's
policies to get a prosecutor fired uh in
Ukraine in six hours so his son would
continue to get paid for something he
was not qualified for by his own
admission if that was Donald Trump Jr if
that was Eric Trump or any Trump you
think they'd get away with that you
think the media would try to have a
blackout on that there's no question
that they would go after Donald Trump I
mean and and Don Jr or anybody else that
was involved look the truth is that Joe
Biden is on tape in January of 2016
saying if you don't get rid of the
prosecutor on barisma where my son is on
the board United not going to get a
billion dollars of our money Sean this
is our taxpayers money he is leveraging
that against a prosecutor I'm going to
ask you a question Sean when is the last
time you heard Joe Biden go after any
prosecutor in the United States ever
what have you ever heard him talk about
any prosecutor nobody's Prosecuting
crime of the progressive DA's he could
care less he only cares where his son is
getting money and let me continue with
that just for a second when Joe Biden
and and and the whole the Democrat Party
you've got Victoria Newland you've got
John Kerry saying you know we're we're
thrilled with what's going on over there
in Ukraine and then all of a sudden Joe
Biden decides he's going to focus on
this prosecutor because he wants to
bring down the corruption in the barisma
company and now we've got we've got a
prosecutor who's a friend with Beau
Biden who is hesitant to indict Hunter
Biden but for whistleblowers who had
everything to lose and nothing to gain
this is a corrupt criminal justice
system and Department of Justice so you
have Hunter benefiting and according to
James Comer a total of nine Biden family
members implicate benefiting financially
from this all these shell corporations
um and I'm looking at this judge and I'm
thinking hold on a second none of them
are qualified what did the grandchildren
do to make that money I'd really like to
know hopefully one day we'll find out
what did Hunter do except maybe put you
know when they need when Barista needed
DC help he got them in touch with with
Joe Biden five days before he did
Leverage that money when he was in Dubai
with Barista Executives you know I I
look at all of this and now we know from
the hunter from Hunter Biden's laptop
from hell that Joe Biden he implicates
his own father benefiting financially
through paying for home repairs all
there Sean this circumstantial evidence
there's direct evidence there's emails
there's admissions there's photographs
there's bank records there's all kinds
of shell corporation's 20 shell
corporations this is corrupt as the day
is is long and it is really a sad
commentary but you know what the
chickens are coming home to roost it's
not going to last that much longer the
walls are caving in and I think enough
Democrats privately probably probably
don't want him as the nominee uh in the
bullpen watch out for Gavin Newsom
that's my warning yep uh I agree have a
great weekend judge we appreciate you
being with us thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else